Jam Jam the winner of Survivor 44.
congratulations how are you feeling
today you're that your big win now is
finally out there for everyone to see
friends family and fans how are you
feeling
I'm so excited I can finally talk about
it oh my God holding that secret is like
not being able to go to the bathroom for
10 months it's like crazy
I'm able to I'm able to finally scream
to the world
I still cannot believe it I play with
the most amazing people and it's still
in shock
oh I can only imagine having to hold on
to that secret for so long but it's
finally out there and I know everyone
here at ET Canada is so excited for you
um you know you won by a pretty much a
landslide seven to one were you
surprised with how the votes played out
from the jury
well I wanted all of them but it's okay
um
I was surprised I thought I thought
Carolyn was gonna get one or two votes
um
we all had mad respect for her and Heidi
so
I would have been happy with any results
but having seven votes from that jury
that's tough Jerry you saw their faces
oh my God the questions were amazed you
know I was like can we just get to the
pizza and the champagne
I know the questions were amazing and
speaking of one of the questions my
favorite pitch or part of your pitch
last night was when you were talking
about how you used you know people's
emotions and their facial expressions to
figure out if they were lying or not I
was like that was the moment I think
that it sealed the deal for a lot of
them because all their boats were pretty
much open but was there a moment during
final tribal for you that you felt okay
I think I have this in the bag I think
my pitch or this part of my pitch really
sealed the deal
that was definitely my highlight coming
out of that finals Rebel console being
able to put into words how I feel and I
normally act around people
because this is something that I've
always known inside my head but I've
never had to talk about it but you're
put in a situation where you have to not
only explain your game but explain how
you did it
um their reactions were instant as soon
as I told them and Fran is saying like
oh my God or something like that
friendly reacted to
I knew that my words were Landing
exactly where I needed them to land so
it was really really really
proud of myself I'm just like I cannot
believe it though I cannot you should be
really proud of yourself I feel like you
really everything you said I was like
tick tick tick I was like this is a
Survivor winner and I was so happy now I
have to point out it's been 15 years
since we had an lgbtq plus winner on
Survivor and you were also the first
lgbtq person of color to win the game
how does that feel for you to be able to
represent those communities on such a
big platform
eight
it's so humbling
um to be able to represent
a community that
I'm so proud to be part of like
like I think that I always think like
word like a little you know magic beans
around the world you know like
live life with joy and be yourself and
have your journey of life and a lot of
people suffer to be
a hundred percent who they are and to be
accepted and
it also took me a little while to become
comfortable with who I am
and
I was the only way I could have played
to be a hundred percent and to be
accepted by my other castmates and loved
and given the reward of winning
I hope other people that look like me
are like me or feel identified in some
way maybe my energy or
their struggles in their life know that
you are just
right there's nothing wrong with you you
are a hundred percent perfect
just you have to love yourself you have
to look in the mirror and say yeah it's
okay to be like this so to be able to
represent and after 15 years
after thought oh my God I love Todd it's
really exciting too
be on that list exactly and you should
be so proud and I know so many people
are like I what has the outpouring of
Love online been like like have you had
a chance to even look and see what the
fans are saying I have no idea
like I'm barely reading my messages from
my friends and I'm getting texts from my
co-workers my employees my friend and
they're like
I'm so proud of you thank you for
showing me that
your dreams can come true and
I'm like filled with joy
oh well then you're gonna have to check
later because the love and all the
support is out there online I saw it all
on Twitter so make sure you check it out
I know it's overwhelming but you gotta
check it out
um also I the whole season I love yours
and Carolyn's friendship and just the
dynamic it was so up and down but I love
watching it are you still as close with
Carolyn now as you were on the show
it's always Caroline every day I talk
with Carlene every day I thought with
Carson every day I talked with Jamie
Heidi every day
um Carolyn is
everything you see in this screen times
a thousand
she is a lot and I love it she's great
she's like a ball of energy of love and
a very very special human being I'm so
lucky to be her friend
oh I love that so much now I have to ask
you do you have any plans for your
million dollar prize do you have
anything you want to get or what you
want to do are you being smart are you
going to splurge what's the what's the T
on that I've been asked about this so
much and I I was like saying I was gonna
deposit it but you know I'm so tired I
might buy a new mattress like a really
fancy mattress oh my God I'm so ready to
sleep I'm so tired like this has been
this secret has been exhausting
oh I can only imagine and probably doing
so many amazing interviews today and
just everything happening last night I
can only imagine how tired you were so
maybe you should treat yourself to a new
mattress
oh my God why not why not no yeah
splurged gotta do it now lastly I have
to ask you know 26 days on the island in
Fiji
after everything that you've been
through winning the game what would you
say was your biggest takeaway from your
time on the show or what did you learn
about yourself
I have this new power like unleash like
you know how you like go through games
and you like level up or you like open
this new domains or like areas
this
Wayne and this success in the game and
the experience itself
help me understand that anything I put
my mind to I can do anything anything
like life is Limitless
and it's very powerful it's very
powerful
that's amazing life is Limitless I love
that well thank you so much Jam jam it
was an absolute pleasure watching you on
Survivor 44 and congratulations once
again and I hope you're able to get some
sleep and maybe on your new mattress
ah yes